مسلسل الكاسر دراما عراقيه من بطوله
الفنان العراقي غالب جواد واخراج ايمن
ناصر زيدان وبيتحدث عن صراع عشائري قائم
على الثار والتمرد المسلسل عامل ازمه
اخذ حق الناس كلها قريه قاصد وابو عقاب
راح اخليها تصير تحت حكم جاسم
خلصنا منهم يقتلوني اقتلوك ما جابتها امه
اللي قلت لك
المسلسل ما حدد عشائر اي منطقه لكن الناس
من السياق واللبس وغيرها من تفاصيل فهمت
انه العشائر في الجنوب وطلعت الاصوات
المعترضه واللي بتهاجم قناه يو تي في
العارضه للمسلسل الانتقادات والاحتجاجات
ما حدد التفصيله معينه فيها الاساءه بس
الناس فهمت ان المقصود ظهور شيخ العشيره
في مجال اسمه موسيقى وسهروا انه يعني
مطلعينه في صوره غير لائقه بحسب المنتقدين
فوفود شعبيه وعشائريه استفزتهم احداث
المسلسل وراحوا على هيئه الاعلام
والاتصالات وطالبوا بايقاف عرضه حتى في
نواب ما كانوا بعيدين عن استنكار المسلسل
وفينا بخاطب هيئه الاعلام والاتصالات وقال
انه احداثه بتشوه الحقائق وبتسيء للمجتمع
العشائري الجنوبي وبتمس بتقاليد العشائر
الاصيله ولا حتى بتلتزم بالضوابط
الاخلاقيه للشهر الفضيل امام الانتقادات
والمطالبات النيابيه والعشائريه وقفت
نقابه الفنانين العراقيين
وداف منه وقالت انه هي الهيئه اللي اجازه
المسلسل بحكم تخصصها وانها مش شايفه في اي
اساءه ودعت المطالبين بايقاف المسلسل لترك
اللغه هذه ومتابعه العمل للاخر ولكن هيئه
الاعلام والاتصالات ما يبدو اقناعتها
دعوات النقابه لانها استجابت للضغوط وكان
قرارات توجيه قناه يو تي في بضروره ايقاف
مسلسل الكاسر وقالت انها بتقدر المطالبات
العشائريه وقالت انها راح تتخذ كافه
الاجراءات الكفيله بالحفاظ على مكانه
المواطن الجنوبي الكريم قناه يو تي في
وكرد على اللي صار طلعت بيان قالت في انه
قرار الهيئه هذا مجحف وانفعالي وفي انسياق
وراء اجندات سياسيه واستجابه لضغوط
ومزايدات سياسيه وطائفيه ومناطقيه بكل اسف
ولو انه الهيئه شكلت لجان مختصه للتعمق في
المسلسل ما كانت اخذت هذا القرار وانه
الهيئه ما قدمت اي مبرر لايقاف عرض
المسلسل وحذ ف حلقاته واكدت انها ما
بتنتمي لاي حزب او حركه وانها بتقدر اهل
الجنوب العراقي وبتحترمهم واللي بيفتح
موقع القناه مشاهدينا او قناه على يوتيوب
راح يشوف انه الحلقات لسه موجوده والحلقات
الجديده بتنزل عادي كمان